[Musique]
faisons serait un rêve pour la femme
d'aujourd'hui mais qui sera la réalité
de demain ou plutôt d'après demain en
l'an 2000 vous pourrez madame
transmettre instantanément votre
commande manuscrite par téléscripteur
use encore plus de mauvaises surprises
sur le premier choix par des visions le
boucher vous fralib et même à domicile
ces présentations
non pas ce morceau
oui c'est le vide
sans doute cette cuisine de rêve est
elle une anticipation des arts ménagers
mais elle est aussi un laboratoire dont
les audaces devenu bientôt réalité
pratique transformera radicalement notre
vie quotidienne
recevoir sans être obligé d'ouvrir sa
porte les livraisons des fournisseurs
directement dans ce réfrigérateur
rotatif qui peut contenir six mois
d'approvisionnement
en appuyant sur un bouton à obtenir à
volonté glace en cubes de glace pilée
boissons chaudes ou froides et l'on
prévoit pour plus tard leur distribution
par pipe line
[Musique]
flanqué de casiers des vapeurs contenant
tous les ustensiles nécessaires le
fourneau et d'une conception insolite en
argot d'italie il a la propriété de
cuire les aliments par chauffage à
induction vous pourrez badham touché la
plaque où l'on bout elle restera pour
vous mme
[Musique]
mieux encore dans un classeur vous
choisirez le plat que vous désirez la
carte perforée correspondante introduite
dans une machine vous expliquera
visuellement larsen tandis qu'un
calculateur électronique que belgrade
osera les ingrédients nécessaires et
animera les robots chargé de la
préparation
[Musique]
ce génie familier s'occuperont aussi de
veau rôti l'heure du dîner choizil
calculeront d'après le point l'heure à
laquelle les infrarouges auront cuites à
point ce poulet que vous n'aurez même
pas la peine d'apporter à vos invités
car ce service invisible mais présent
les total poursuivra jusqu'à va pas
[Musique]
à une lacune cependant dans cette magie
moderne des dispositifs où le robot a
pris la place de l'homme le robot ne
s'est pas encore découper le poulet
[Musique]